[Música]
tres notas de música a baja velocidad
para sustituir el sonido de un motor que
ya no se oye acercarse el vehículo está
muy estable en la carretera se asienta
bien en las suspensiones en comparación
con un motor diésel donde todo el peso
se distribuye hacia la parte delantera
del vehículo ha mantenido el mismo
aspecto desde su lanzamiento en la
década de 1940 pero bajo la carrocería
de este emblemático autobús escolar
estadounidense se ha producido una
pequeña revolución esperan el motor que
está aquí es mucho más pequeño que un
motor de combustión sólo tiene 20 piezas
en comparación con el motor de
combustión interna que tiene 2.000
piezas hasta el mar
sólo hay 3 piezas que gira misma que
están en movimiento eso hace que estos
motores vayan a tener una longevidad
extrema porque hay poco movimiento y
poca fricción autobuses escolares pero
también naves espaciales o este gran
transportista inaugurado antes que el
gigante estadounidense tesla totalmente
eléctrico
los pedidos llegan sin parar ya en 2010
decidimos ser 100% eléctricos todo el
mundo decía que estábamos locos por
aquel entonces pero al día de hoy quedó
demostrado que hemos tomado la decisión
correcta una elección útil y ecológica
gracias al saber hacer local y ahora
reconocida la pequeña empresa de quebec
suministrar a autobuses al distrito
escolar más grande de california con un
gran impulso del sector público 100
millones de dólares para su próxima
planta de ensamblaje de baterías los
nervios de la guerra contra los mercados
asiáticos
proyectos como este y si seguimos
trabajando juntos en la misma dirección
superaremos estos objetivos
alcanzaremos el objetivo de cero en
acciones para 2050 y canadá que no ha
cumplido con el acuerdo climático de
parís está tratando de acelerar el ritmo
en su carrera hacia las energías limpias
y es en quebec donde se libra gran parte
de la batalla de la innovación hola
rafael
como esta sus empresas se exportan en
todo el mundo transformadores turbinas
palas de aerogeneradores y servicios de
consultoría de ingeniería y software
hablé un poco de la ciberseguridad
porque eso también es parte de las
apuestas de este tipo de equipos allí y
en el sector de la electrificación que
venga ha recibido una muy buena noticia
este año el cambio de rumbo ecológico de
su poderoso vecino el primer socio
comercial eeuu que ve que está
especialmente bien posicionado
geográficamente porque se está
convirtiendo en la batería del noreste
del continente y por tanto las
posibilidades de exportar energía
eléctrica son reales y se están
realizando y también la posibilidad de
atender un mercado que está en plena
transformación con el plan by del que
todo el mundo habla que le deja un lugar
importante las energías renovables se
trata de decisiones que se remontan a
varias décadas atrás pero que
actualmente sitúan a quebec en una
posición prácticamente única con la
hidroelectricidad
obviamente encabezando la lista energía
eólica y de solar ahora en pleno
desarrollo
con su medio millón de lagos y ríos que
ve que es el campeón americano de la
hidroelectricidad pero antes de cantar
victoria sobre el calentamiento global
los quebequenses tendrán que cambiar su
estilo de vida porque también están
entre los mayores consumidores de
energía del mundo aquí las ventas de
camionetas incluyendo las de platón y
camiones que consumen mucha gasolina
casi se han triplicado en 30 años una
aberración entre otras que anula a todas
las ganancias dice pies olivia espinal
cuyos informes sobre el estado de la
energía en quebec son muy seguidos
tenemos un buen ejemplo de aberración
energética cuando utilizamos la madera
como lo hemos hecho aquí para la
calefacción directa de los edificios
sino para transformarla en electricidad
y esa electricidad allí se va a utilizar
para la calefacción de los edificios a
menudo utilizados al servicio de una
agenda política a corto plazo los vastos
recursos naturales de la provincia
deberían explotar se de otra manera
afirma viejo olivia aquí no tenemos un
sistema energético muy politizado y muy
a menudo el gobierno utiliza
para adjudicar contratos en las regiones
industria forestal por ejemplo que pasa
regularmente por crisis el gobierno
quiere acudir a rescatarla eso
contribuye a un sistema energético que
no es del todo racional está demasiado
politizado tiene consecuencias positivas
para el desarrollo económico de ciertas
regiones pero se produce a costa de
aberraciones energéticas
ante el notable fracaso del anterior
plan de acción para reducir los gases de
efecto invernadero el gobierno
provincial ha presentado un ambicioso
plan de electrificación y cambio
climático hasta 2030 esperando liderar
el resto de canadá en energía verde